some of you have probably finished Final
Fantasy 15 by now so it's a good thing
DLC is already on the way I'm Tony and
this is your holiday themed game spot
news update Final Fantasy 15 s first
add-on is the holiday pack this free DLC
adds a level stopper a new victory song
a new shirt for Noctis and a ticket to
the in-game mughal carnival season pass
owners can grab the holiday pack plus
which adds all of that plus a protection
ring to boosters to more victory songs
and other in-game items both packs will
be available on december twenty seconds
and update the same day we'll add new
game+ though details on that are scarce
at the moment Final Fantasy 15 is one of
many games to release on ps4 and xbox
one and 2016 and you can check out
GameSpot's top five for both of those
platforms right now and tune into a game
of the year live stream on Tuesday
December twentieth at ten a.m. Pacific
will have all sorts of special guests
and prizes for you there for all the
latest on Final Fantasy you're already
in the right place